- [Mark] All right, Alex.
Alex, where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- [Alex] I grew up in
La Canada, California,
in between Pasadena and La Crescenta.
A lot of people don't
know exactly where it is,
but it's a small kind of
bubble, very wealthy town.
- [Mark] Yeah, basically
outside of Pasadena.
And how'd you grow up?
With both your parents?
- Yes.
Both my parents were...
Yes, they raised me.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
- Some parts were good.
Some parts were bad.
My mom was a very violent alcoholic,
very condescending, violent.
She was the type of person that
if I got a 95 on a test,
she'd be like,
"Okay, well, you couldn't get 100?"
I just never felt good enough.
So, that kind of messed
with my self-esteem.
And when she got drunk
she was very violent
and she knew how to scrap.
So it was kind of rough at some points.
- [Mark] And then where'd your
life go when you left home?
- Well, actually, I got
kicked out when I was 19,
right after high school.
I got held back in sixth grade.
And two months out of high school,
my dad passed away,
- [Mark] Sorry.
- And I moved back home.
And then I went to Santa
Barbara City College
to try to get a degree
in about 2011,
I believe.
He passed away 2010.
So.
- [Mark] And how'd you end up down here?
- [Alex] So basically,
I started using heroin in Santa Barbara.
Of course it got dry.
I knew somebody down
here that could get some.
I went on vacation with
my mom to San Diego
and my friend drug dealer wasn't
picking up and I was sick.
And so I didn't know what to do.
And I just dro...
I literally took her car,
drove three hours from San
Diego, unbeknownst to her,
to Skid Row,
driving around, asking people,
"You know where I can
get this, that, this?"
- [Mark] Did it take you longer
than two minutes to find it?
- [Alex] It literally, it
probably took about maybe,
yeah, 10 minutes.
10 minutes of...
Yeah.
And that's what started it.
- [Mark] And then are
you staying down here?
- [Alex] No, I'm not staying down here.
- [Mark] Here's not good enough?
- [Alex] Yeah, unfortunately.
- [Mark] So where do you live now?
- [Alex] I live in Pasadena.
- [Mark] Okay.
And are you working at all?
- [Alex] I used to work at
P.F. Chang's for two years.
And in order for me to get
sober, I decided to quit.
But that didn't really work out,
but
I actually...
of course, drug addicts have a plan
but I have these medications
that will help me get on,
something called Suboxone
which you can wean yourself off of.
And so that was the main
reason coming down here,
is to, try to help me get sober.
So I'm looking at the next
week hopefully to get sober
and really like do this thing.
I'm miserable.
Yeah, it's a very soul sucking...
- [Mark] How long have you been using?
- Over the span of seven years,
on and off.
Longest I had sober was 16 months.
- [Mark] And do your parents know you're
using heroin?
- My dad never knew before he died.
He knew I smoked weed,
but yes, my mother does know,
unfortunately.
- [Mark] And then what
are you doing for money?
- What I do for money,
another long story,
grandparents passed away.
They had a trust fund for me,
since my dad wasn't alive.
The trust went to natural born Bertus,
which is my last name.
So my mom didn't get it.
So my brother and I,
every year we get 5% of
the money from this trust.
And at first, when I
was sober, it was great.
I was doing good.
And then the second I relapsed,
my habit was out of control.
And yeah, it's a blessing in disguise.
So I'm hoping this next year,
that's why I'm trying
to get clean right now
is so like I don't start the
next year with all this money
and just
blow it all and waste on my life.
Man, I love my life.
I hate the way I'm living right now.
- [Mark] And do you have any
relationships with anybody?
I mean, do you have friends?
Do you have a girlfriend,
anything like that?
- I actually...
Yeah, I did have an ex-girl...
Or I did have a girlfriend,
she cheat on me, I kicked her out.
Actually my best friend just
passed away on the 23rd.
His funeral was yesterday.
- [Mark] (mumbles) sorry.
- And
yeah, so it's...
And then I found out this morning that
my brother is an early alcoholic,
my dad passed away in his arms.
And
they said that his liver is so bad
that he has a 50/50 chance
of dying in the next 90 days.
So, we're all just praying for him and
it's also surreal.
It's all like, "Holy shit, man."
And that's another reason
why I want to shape up.
- [Mark] How did your friend pass away?
- They found him next to a
meth pipe, which is strange
'cause usually people don't
pass away from a meth pipe.
So my home girl thinks it
was laced with fentanyl
or something,
but we don't know.
And I'm not about to ask his family.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Wow.
Well, good luck with everything, man.
Thank you so much for talking to me.
- [Alex] I grew up from a
relatively wealthy family.
I had opportunities like
no other, and I still do.
- [Mark] That doesn't mean
you're immune to (mumbles).
- [Alex] (mumbles) addict.
- [Mark] Happens to everybody.
- [Alex] Exactly.
- [Mark] Okay, thank you.
- Yeah, absolutely, man.
Thank you so much.